do you know someone that needs help to
switch the digital television is
switching to digital all over the UK and
the traditional TV signal will be
switched off in your area if you don't
have digital TV by the time of the
switchover you will lose your TV
channels most people are ready for
switchover but there may be people you
know that need help to make the switch
the switchover help scheme has launched
a helping hand campaign to make sure
every eligible older and disabled person
in the area knows about the help they
can get from the BBC run help scheme to
convert one of their TV sets to digital
eligible people have been posted a Help
scheme information pack explaining the
offer and will also receive a follow-up
reminder letter the helping hand
campaign urges everyone who has already
switched to digital to reach out to
those older and disabled people they
know who may still need help do you have
family or friends or know of someone in
your local community who may need help
to switch over to ensure that no one is
left behind lend them a helping hand by
passing this information to them all
help them to get in touch with the help
scheme you may be the one person they
trust to give them good advice most
people will be asked to pay 40 pound
toward the standard option of help the
service is also free for people who are
eligible and will also receive printing
credit income support income-based
jobseeker's allowance or income related
employment and support allowance people
are eligible for the help scheme if
their age 75 all over or have lived in a
care home for six months or more or get
or could get disability living allowance
or attendance or constant attendance
alone
or mobility supplement supplement or are
registered blind or partially sighted
for more information call Oh 800 408
5900 or visit WWLP scheme co uk text
phone users can call oh 800 4085 936 for
general information and guidance on
switch over please fit visit digital UK
co uk
do you play sports or playing pitches
are there any playing pitch is close to
where you live are you or your children
an active member of a football hockey
rugby or cricket club do you have ideas
on how to improve sports pitches and
ancillary facilities in a cost-effective
way or is there anything that you would
like to see the council do to improve
the playing pictures in the district if
you answered yes to any of the questions
then the council wants to hear from you
when the playing pitch strategy goes out
to consultation shortly your suggestions
will be used to draw up a future plan
for playing pictures across the district
rochford district council has a major
role to play in ensuring that future
playing pitch provision meets changing
patterns of demand an up-to-date
strategy is being prepared to assess
current and future playing pitch
provision across the district and to
investigate the current ability to meet
these needs in terms of quality
availability accessibility and also
access to other outdoor sports
facilities the strategy will provide a
concise and accurate strategy for the
provision of playing pitches and will
replace the previous 2007 strategy when
adopted the revised strategy will
function as a supplementary planning
document within the local development
framework providing advice and guidance
on playing pitch provision and
improvements needed and why we're doing
this playing pitches support thriving
leagues and other tournaments in
different sports and we recognise the
key role that local sports clubs and
schools play in sports development your
views are important to help us identify
where improvements might be needed to
meet demand the key objectives of this
strategy are to analyse the current
balance between the supply and demand of
playing pitches within the district and
the quality of the pictures through the
use of the revised playing pitch
methodology developed by Sport England
determine the accessibility of each
playing pitch in relation to the
surrounding population identify areas
which require additional investment in
order to meet the needs of the local
community interpret the demand for
playing pictures in the district both
now and in the future draw informative
conclusions on the future of playing
pitches in the district and suggest
recommendations for guiding local
policies such as areas requiring
improvements and proposals for the
provision of new playing pitches in line
with national guidance the council is
currently awaiting feedback from Sport
England before we go out to consultation
on the playing pitch strategy
supplementary planning document once the
consultation starts we will advertise
for comments through local and
electronic media including the council's
website where the draft will be
available to download as well as
contacting those on our mailing list if
you wish to be added to the council's
mailing list please listen to the next
article about have your say postcards
are you on the Planning Policy mailing
list to be kept up to date on the local
development framework if so look out for
one of Rochford district councils
postcards coming through your letterbox
across the Rochford district thousands
of residents have asked to be kept
informed about opportunities to have
their say on planning policy
consultations at the moment just over
half of the eight and a half thousand
individuals and companies who have asked
to be kept updated on opportunities to
submit their views on proposed planning
policies are contacted by email while
others receive a letter we want to make
the best use of our available resources
and be more environmentally friendly so
for future consultations those who
currently receive a letter through the
postal service will now start to receive
a postcard instead the postcard will
always be the same size but the
information on the front will order to
reflect which document we are asking you
to comment on the council is currently
working towards the production of a plan
for the district which will set out what
the area will look like in the future
this development plan is known as the
local development framework or ldf the
LDF is a collection of documents which
together will play an important role in
shaping and managing development in the
district documents for me the LDF
include us call strategy and the
allocations document to name just a few
over the last few years we have been
asking for your opinions on planning
policies of the district in order to
ensure that future development reflects
your views in that time we have had a
fantastic response from you and
thousands of comments and suggestions
submitted submitted on a range of
planning matters from the designation of
local wildlife sites to the location of
housing to the future of London's
Southend Airport if you are not on our
mailing list but would like to be
notified of future opportunities to
participate in the production of the LDF
and have access to the internet simply
visit rochford dot j dì hyphen consult
dotnet forward slash
ldf and click register now alternatively
you can contact the planning policy on 0
1 702 318 191 or email planning policy
at Rochford got you k
nine council car parks awarded part mark
status rotifer district council has once
a dane achieved the safer parking scheme
park marked awards for all nine of its
pay and display car parks what is the
safer parking scheme park mark is a
nationwide initiative of the Association
of Chief Police Officers ACPO aimed at
reducing crime and the fear of crime in
parking facilities the scheme is managed
by the British parking association on
behalf of ACP oh and supported by the
Home Office and scottish executive how
are the awards achieved the awards are
granted to parking areas that have
achieved the requirements of both a risk
assessment conducted by the police and a
review of the management practices of
the operator carried out by the british
parking association what has watched the
done to achieve this watch the District
Council manages its own car parks and
over a number of years has made
improvements the help to deter criminal
activity and anti-social behavior we are
committed to doing everything we can to
prevent crime and reduce the fear of
crime in our car parks areas that have
been reviewed our boundaries and
parameters crime recording and
statistics lighting management practice
parking areas pedestrian access signage
surveillance vehicular access why should
I use a pulp mark car park because the
car park has been assessed by the police
and has measures in place that create a
safer environment for both you and your
vehicle visits ww pockmark co uk for
more information
new statistics show that England's lyssa
problem is getting worse the good news
is a national campaign called love where
you live has been launched by the keep
britain tidy group to try and combat
this the campaign intends to raise
awareness about everyone taking
responsibility to care for and protect
where they live by getting involved with
litter picks or other activities which
may help keep the local environment
clean and tidy there are already several
community groups running their own
litter pigs getting involved can be a
great way of meeting people and doing
your bit to keep the district a
beautiful place to live work and visit
the council is encouraging both
individuals and groups to organize their
own litter picks during the official
love where you live week which takes
place during the week commencing the
19th of September 2211 there will be a
series of events taking place across the
country so why not get together with
friends or family and take part it
doesn't matter how long you spent
picking litter or how much you collect
it all helps to improve our district the
love where you live campaign is already
on Facebook and Twitter so log on to
find out more about what's happening and
join up with others to tackle the low
litter problem we'd love to hear your
ideas for love where you live week
events or if you're planning to organize
a letter pick so get in touch using the
local contact details which are you can
email customer services at Rochford gov
UK or call 0170 2318 one double one and
ask for customer services
Rotorua District Council has joined a
new scheme designed to keep residents
informed about air quality not just in
the district but also across the county
the Essex air quality consortium aims to
provide as much information as possible
to people living in Essex about air
quality in the area where you live the
consortium has its own website WWDC org
UK which contains useful information and
educational resources for adults and
children alike the site can give you up
to date readings of air quality
statistics from across the county and
there's also an action-packed section
for young people with lots of games and
information to enjoy rochford District
Council's portfolio holder for the
environment councillor Mike steptoe said
this is a fantastic and very worthwhile
project which aims to ensure that
residents in rochford and across essex
can have the quality of air to match the
quality of life there is here air
pollution does not respect local
authority boundaries so a partnership
such as this where several experts in
their field regularly meet and work
together and share their findings on the
website is a great idea the consortium
consists of all local authorities Essex
County Council the Environment Agency
London Stansted Airport and the
University of Essex
you